so for you you bring this guy along uh
you needed a host he's obviously been
doing a really good job of producing
content for your wife indicted to me and
then uh you're on no jumper yeah doing
the news and such have you done some
interviews on there too right yeah I've
done a couple interviews uh what made
you bring icon in icon was uh I just
felt like it was already tapped in with
the scene he was a videographer he
already knew all the artists especially
in the Latin Market in LA right so he
was already tapped in and I needed
someone who knows or in each and icon
just fit the description and I feel like
he was a perfect fit what is your I'm
not too hip to like I know you're like
[__] you've been around La for a long
time but icon give me kind of like your
background
so I was from a hip-hop group Once Upon
a Time called The Campaign we had our
[__] hosted by Julio G Tony G
some of our projects um I've been
filming music videos the entire time uh
the very first time I synced the music
to the [__] camera footage was uh
J-Rock and glasses Malone and L boy
video
uh back in the day have you heard Elle
boy um pretty cool Latin rapper uh and
yeah ever since I've been shooting music
videos and I did the rap [__] I
eventually got signed a brown side have
you heard of brown side I've heard of
brown side when they made the Resurgence
I was shooting their music videos they
decided some one day that they wanted me
to continue rapping for them and I was
like [__] it so you used to be a rapper
see I didn't know there used to be a
rapper yeah so you were I intend on
coming up here and jumping the freestyle
and [__] on all your favorite
artists oh really you're about to rap
not today are you gonna get back into it
uh nah
oh well because I'm up I should
capitalize and drop music at [__] my
late 30s
why not uh I'm definitely gonna we're
gonna do a cipher series and I'm
definitely gonna drop the first one
it'll be like big TIG you know like how
TIG would I respect that I respect that
narrative hey coming rap I'm gonna drop
a freestyle you know it's fire you know
not bad I like that idea why don't you
do that I can't rap you're you're a
rapper fool you I heard the project you
got a gold plaque in there with your
name on it yeah no bad I didn't rap no
wrapping here sir
if I could rap I probably still would I
like it I'm 36. I'm old I'm white you
know here's what it is
um so but what what area of uh I'm from
east L.A I'm from El Sereno to be exact
okay
did you come up like because I feel like
you're uh you didn't have any graffiti
[__] in your background or am I tripping
I mean everyone that was a gang member
tagged at one point right
I suppose that's that's the case yeah
I'm not gonna disclose all of that right
now but yeah
and a legend gang member yeah of course
of course I'm a good guy you're a great
guy
um so you end up kind of having like a
turning your music career into being the
video guy which is that went hand in
hand because I had an Empire deal like
12 years ago ah so you already was
rocking with gazi early early
I was rocking with my homie cavie but
yeah essentially yeah that's crazy dude
so you were shooting videos and putting
out music at the same time and for a
while it was cool and then when I
started doing the brown side [__] I got
a little bit more popular so I kind of
took a baby step back and then the owner
of my record label got assassinated in
Mexico that's like a well-documented
thing if you look up talk or brown side
it's like a thing
and when that happened I just decided
like he was the the glue over there so
when he died I had just released my
album and I thought it would be like a
scummy thing to do to like capitalize on
the notoriety we got from his death so I
just
broke off just did my own show yeah I'll
just continue with the video why'd they
kill him
I don't know exactly but they definitely
it was definitely really rough they uh
abducted them from his home in front of
his wife and kid and uh
they shot him several times and they put
him on the side of the road in Mexico so
what years would you say where you're
like Peak rapping like years just so I
can kind of get engaged and what like
2012 to maybe 2017. okay so hey that's
not long ago dude it's not that long ago
yeah so for you like what made you kind
of like go all in on the content and
like you want to know what it's kind of
weird how that happened to be quite
honest because I started doing like a
little podcast with my boy called the
sauce and um when I was doing that I
looked at my wife and my wife has a
pretty Dynamic story and I was like
I think we're gonna make you tell your
story not on my podcast I gave her her
own [__] so from one day to the next I I
built a set or whatever I mean it's not
that crazy just prison clothes right so
I hit up all my homies nobody it's a
clean set because I didn't know that
that was your wife because I've seen her
stuff pop up no yeah it's pretty it's I
don't want to say it's super viral but
it's definitely a widespread
so um yeah from one day to the next she
did a time in prison she did uh she did
five on a RICO Act she got federally
indicted on the RICO Act did you know
her prior to that or did you I had met
her did I no I didn't know her that was
in 2008 when she got Rico indicted okay
I had met her maybe like around 2012.
through one of my buddies from the from
the group
it was like they're from wherever
they're from in Northeast L.A it's a
popular gang over there and
um she just showed up to be like an
extra in a music video we were doing
like a liquor store robbery she was like
one of the patrons of the liquor store
and now my girl was there at the time
she pulled up just oh hi bye whatever
cool cordial [__] and then yeah your
other girl your previous girl mm-hmm
actually
I ain't mad at him man so then you
executive produce her [__] and then
another show right uh executive produced
her [__] and then I helped produce the
food community and obviously I'm the
host the food Community [__] what for
you like obviously doing a podcast I I
was telling you this like I think it's
like an obvious like you guys are
feeling a a niche like you said like
there really isn't like a Latin hip-hop
podcast in terms of like I mean if there
is like I'm not like super hip so I
could be yeah
no that was the goal too when the food
Community was started I know there was a
void there wasn't really nothing for us
and um that's something I was wanted to
do I always wanted to help put my people
on and I knew it was something that was
needed for you obviously the biggest
full Pages Fool's gone wild right these
guys have sold out the novo they've
toured it's amazing it's it's crazy
right The Branding it's wild do you guys
have any sort of rivalry going going on
or is it like all kosher like nah nah
nah there's a lot of full Pages by the
way oh for sure I would think that
there's nothing at all really it's just
they they cater to a certain uh they
they produce certain type of content
which is you know funny [__] yeah it's
funny I've even sent post over there
shit's hilarious but we're what we do is
more like news and documenting music
stuff that revolves around the culture
things of that nature they're very much
like common or I think a Fool's going on
I think of Comedy you know what I'm
saying yeah